[Aplausos]
aseguró un histórico tercer mandato como
presidente de China un hecho sin
precedentes que vino acompañado de un
nuevo comité permanente del poliburó un
órgano de 7 miembros que constituye la
cúpula de liderazgo de la formación yo
también fue reelegido como secretario
general del congreso del partido
comunista de China y presidente de la
comisión militar central del partido
estamos dando pasos confiados en un
nuevo viaje para convertir a China en un
país socialista moderno en todos los
aspectos para avanzar hacia la meta del
segundo siglo y abrazar El Gran
rejuvenecimiento de los chinos en todos
los frentes a través de un camino hacia
la modernización las nuevas caras de la
cúpula china son
liquián quien supervisó como mano de
hierro los estrictos confinamientos en
Shanghai una política cuya continuidad
fue reiterada por el presidente chip se
perfila como el posible próximo Primer
Ministro kayquian ex alcalde de Beijing
y encargado de supervisar la
organización de los Juegos Olímpicos de
invierno
fue el secretario de Shanghai y el jefe
de gabinete del mandatario Chino
mientras que lichi saltó varios puestos
hasta llegar al cargo del influyente
organismo en corrupción del partido
los cuatro funcionarios son mayores de
60 años y aliados cercanos de chim y es
la primera vez en 25 años que el comité
no cuenta con la presencia de mujeres el
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin y
lier norcoreano Kim Hyun felicitaron así
por su tercer mandato ambos esperando
incrementar la cooperación bilateral con
la segunda Economía del mundo